مساله معقده كما اشرت ما يجعلها كذلك هو
صعوبه اثناء اثبات هذه الجرائم وهذه
الانتهاكات هذه الجرائم تحتاج الى ادله
دامغه اي ادله ماديه وتحتاج ايضا او الى
شهود مباشرين المشكله اننا ما زلنا في عز
الحرب هناك طبعا اتهامات الان الاوكرانيون
يحاولون توثيق ما يجري هناك محققون
كلما حدث قصف او حدث هجوم على منطقه
يوثقون الخسائر يجمعون الادله ويفحصون حتى
الجثث يا اما يوثقون هويتها حتى اذا لم
يسمح ذلك عن طريق الاهل اذا كانت الجثه
متحلله مثلا يتم اللجوء الى الحمض النووي
بمعنى انهم يعدون الادله لمثل هذه
المحاكمه التي تتطلب طبعا وقتا هي لا يمكن
تكون هنا وان كان الاوكرانيون يعولون في
مرحله ما كانوا يعولون على ان المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه على تحركها خلال بدايه
هذه الحرب على اعتبار ان اوكرانيا قد لجات
الى المحكمه الجنائيه منذ 2014
عندما بدات وتم الحاق اقليم شبه جزيره
القرم لجات الى المحكمه الجنائيه المشكله
ان هناك ان اوكرانيا من جهه هي ليست عضوا
في لم توقع على ميثاق المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه مثل روسيا ايضا مشكله الثانيه
ايضا ان المدعي العامه كريم خان لمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه يظل متحفظا الى حد كبير
وفي غياب طبعا الادله وايضا
لحدود
هذه المحكمه التي اسست
عشرين عاما تقريبا ليس في رصيدها مثلا
محاكمات من العيار الثقيل في مثل هذه في
لجرائم مثل هاته و عملها يخضع كثيرا
لميزان القوى ولحسابات سياسيه اوكرانيا
تطالب باحداث محكمه خاصه وهذا ربما هي
تعتقد الاوكرانيون في هذه هذا الهجوم
الحقوقي الذي يشنونه منذ عده اشهر يعتقدون
ان في حال احداث محكمه خاصه
بالعدوان بما يسمونه العدوان محكمه خاصه
بالعدوان على اوكرانيا فان ذلك
اثبات جريمه العدوان هي مساله سهله جدا
وتوصل الى راس السلطه في موسكو على اعتبار
ان فلاديمير بوتين بنفسه اعترف
وتبنى عمليه اجتياح اوكرانيا والدخول الى
اوكر بان جريمه العدوان اذا اثبتتها هيئه
قضائيه فان بقيه الجرائم تنبع منها
والمسؤوليه ثابته على راس هرم السلطه هي
تريد ان تلجا الى هذه الوسيله المشكله ان
المحكمه الجنائيه ليس من اختصاصها او
افرغت ان شئت من هذا الاختصاص اي ادانه او
الحكم على عدوان لان كانت هناك سوابق
وكانت في الحقيقه من افرغها هم الغرب في
النهايه الولايات ضغوط من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فرنسا وبريطانيا وقتها
عام
2010 على خلفيه طبعا اجتياح العراق
لا تتجه الامور في اتجاه ادانه دول بعينها
العداله الدوليه معقده وطبعا
يستغرق وقت حتى في حال اقامه هذه المحكمه
الدوليه للمحكمه
العدوان للنظر في العدوان الروسي على
اوكرانيا وان تحظى اليوم بدعم الاتحاد
الاوروبي للاتحاد الاوروبي صوت على
احداثها فانها تحتاج الى وقت طويل اولا
لانشائها وتحتاج الى وقت اطول ايضا لايجاد
توافق حولها شكرا